geht es zu ende mit unserer zivilisation
zumindest deuten einige anzeichen darauf
hin und es gibt sogar mathematische
modelle die den untergang als
unausweichlich berechnen jetzt in
clixoom science und fiction
das papier ist 27 seiten dick und stellt
ein mathematisches modell dar mit dem
der zusammenbruch von zivilisationen
berechnet werden kann
das modell ist umstritten doch stecken
darin grundlagen die von kaum einem
wissenschaftler abgestritten werden denn
alle bisher untergegangenen zivilisation
sind nahezu auf die gleiche art und
weise verschwunden und dabei spielt ein
umstand oft eine entscheidende rolle
der verbrauch der natürlichen ressourcen
und der damit verbundenen zerstörung der
umwelt eines der beeindruckendsten
beispiele sind die osterinseln
abgekapselt von anderen kontinenten
richtete sich die kultur dort selbst zu
grunde wohl für die ausrichtung und den
transport der riesigen moai steinfiguren
benötigten sie unmengen holz sie rodeten
ihre wälder
der boden wurde in der folge abgetragen
und das land wurde unfruchtbar
die nahrung wurde knapp und die
verschiedenen gesellschaftlichen gruppen
bekriegten sich und brachten sich
gegenseitig um
dramatisch war es auch bei den maya in
mittelamerika in der hoch-zeit der
kultur von so 304 bis 900 nach christus
bevölkerten bis zu 14 millionen meyer
die region
auch hier waren die folgen der
bevölkerungsexplosion die rodung von
wäldern und die böden wurden ausgelaugt
zwei aufeinanderfolgende dürreperioden
führten zu einer katastrophe es kam zu
hungersnöten die bis zu 99 prozent der
bevölkerung aus löschten
zuvor hatten zwei rivalisierende
herrscher begonnen sich zu bekriegen was
zusammengenommen die dezimierung der
bevölkerung auf nur noch 30.000 maja zur
folge hat und es gibt ohne ende solcher
beispiele nur extrem selten wurden die
richtigen konsequenzen gezogen
eine ausnahme ist zum beispiel die
pazifikinsel topia hier gab es eine
strenge geburtenkontrolle nur der
älteste sohn einer familie dürfte kinder
zeugen
das hatte schlimme konsequenzen alle
anderen säuglinge wurden umgebracht als
die bevölkerung bemerkte dass ihre
schweine zu viele ressourcen
verbrauchten wurden sie alle getötet
all das führte dazu dass die bevölkerung
dort mit immer rund 1000
einwohnern stabil blieb und so 3000
jahre lang bis heute existiert heute
sind es allerdings 1200 menschen
da die geburtenkontrolle gelockert wurde
auch in manchen anderen regionen wurde
rechtzeitig reagiert in neuguinea wurden
schnell wachsende baumarten angepflanzt
um die wälder wieder aufzuforsten und in
japan wurde eine geregelte
forstwirtschaft eingeführt als die
vernichtung der wälder drohte aber was
passiert im moment auf unserem planeten
im amazonasgebiet werden jedes jahr rund
6000 quadratkilometer wald gerodet
tendenz steigend damit wird dort von den
wäldern immer weniger sauerstoff für die
erdatmosphäre produziert zudem
verbrennen wir offensichtlich so viele
fossile brennstoffe dass uns durch immer
mehr co2 in der atmosphäre der
klimawandel droht und unsere meere sind
inzwischen dramatisch überfischt der
1950 noch rund 12 8 millionen tonnen
fisch im jahr gefangen wurden sind es
heute mit rund 50 millionen tonnen das
vierfache der bestand an speisefischen
ist inzwischen um rund 90 prozent
geschrumpft
30 prozent der bestände gelten als
überfischt
in den europäischen fanggebieten sind es
sogar rund 50 wenn es so weitergeht sind
die weltmeere 2050 so gut wie leer
gefischt es gebe nicht mehr genügend
fische für den fischfang
wir sägen also im moment ganz kräftig an
dem ast auf dem wir sitzen in den
mathematischen modell gibt es aber noch
ein faktor entscheidend für den
untergang einer zivilisation ist die
umverteilung von arm zu reich umso mehr
wohlstand sich die eliten sichern desto
instabiler werden gesellschaften durch
diese umverteilung verlieren die eliten
den kontakt zur tatsächlichen
entwicklung und bemerkten die krise
zuletzt dann ist es zu spät und die
krise kann nicht mehr bewältigt werden
bisher hat unsere zivilisation bereits
in vielen fällen noch rechtzeitig
gegengesteuert
zum beispiel das ozonloch das schließt
sich langsam
die eu hat eine fischereireform
beschlossen die bestände in der nordsee
erholen sich bereits wieder
es gibt einzelne beispiele dafür dass
wir noch die kurve kriegen aber es sind
zu wenige was meint ihr
werden wir es schaffen oder werden wir
ein dunkles zeitalter erleben diskutiert
es in den kommentaren ordentlich
diskutiert wurde auch unter dem letzten
video gedanken steuern flugzeug und noch
mehr science und fiction gibt es täglich
hier bei pixum de links wie immer auch
in der video beschreibung also also
nicht vergessen ein abo da lassen wenn
es euch gefallen hat also bis dann
bleibt dran